Iceland the world's largest volcanic
island has a surprising variety of
landscapes and some very unpredictable
weather heavy rains alternate with
snowstorms and sunshine the native sheep
and the hearty horses which the Vikings
brought to Iceland in the 9th century
seem immune to the elements and the
culture and myths of Iceland have
captivated many foreigners we're
visiting claim who was born as Christina
in Germany she's lived here for 20 years
she's become an Icelandic citizen and is
started a family her children are called
Anna and Vicki it all began with feigns
girlhood fascination with Icelandic
horses the Icelanders are traditionally
good hosts and for our visit crane is
making us pancakes yourself in Iceland
that's what attracted me you can live
your dreams and of course you're
prepared to work harder for that it's
also a lot easier to keep horses here
it's all natural it's a lot of work but
it's also a lot of fun about as much
fast
cleans family lives in part from tourism
her husband's fen is a horse expert he
helps her whenever he can in winter
there are hardly any visitors in summer
most of cranes tourists are Germans on
riding vacations our daughter Ana
learned to ride practically when she was
a baby
mother and daughter still enjoy putting
the horses through their paces together
[Music]
in winter Pauline works mostly at a
Technical College in hora where she
trains riding instructors she teaches a
number of young women who just as she
once did have come here to learn more
about horses
Hana Fae from Germany for instance she's
studying the Icelandic language she
wants to earn a bachelor's degree and
says she may stay in Iceland if you
visit Iceland there is no avoiding
horses
[Music]
and the same is true for legends about
elves and trolls I think you'd be
hard-pressed to find an Icelander he
says they don't believe in elves people
in Iceland tend to fill their lives with
work and they have to put up with the
cold and long dark winters
let's encouraged a storytelling
tradition in Iceland Karolina from
Germany a trained engineer likes the
relative isolation of the country since
2010 she's owned a house with sheep and
horses in the highlands I'm someone who
feels a close connection with nature
it's important to me to live in and with
nature and if I can do that I'm happy
cow Alina sometimes buys Icelandic wool
from sea Christianity a farmer she sells
it in Germany 16 it is very well known
and respected in the region he says this
stall is not just home to animals he
tells us a story about the supernatural
Karolina translates for us exactly on
the spot where the old Pete Stoll was
right up front in the middle he once saw
a man the man came through the door here
went to the area where the old stall was
and disappeared singer stayed wasn't the
only one who saw this man many other
people saw him too and the sheep always
veered in that direction so it seems
quite realistic the man was here and he
still is today that's what he believes
anyway yeah that's the sign about so
long
whether you believe in it or not the
supernatural never seems far away in
Iceland
[Music]
when the snow dusts the peaks all around
it's easy to feel transported into a
winter fairy tale
[Music]